we wanted to make the rock band
experience on oculus so realistic that
the player actually feels like they are
a rock star
but we're tech guys and game developers
we didn't know what it was like to
really feel like a rock star clearly we
needed help and then we thought who
better than dragonforce their song
through the fire in the flames is one of
the most difficult songs out there in
the real world and in rock band so we
hired them as consultants to teach us
how to think act and feel like a rock
star these guys needed a lot of work
we're not sure if this will be even
successful so we got them start on a
rigorous training program any questions
yes papa
we're the groupies dude is 10 a.m. it's
not too early for groupies
okay so what is the most important body
part during a guitar solo Alex the
fingers wrong is the face did you see
Herman's facial artistry okay so get
started practicing those solo faces and
we'll be back to check on your progress
in two hours so what do you think of my
a skull guy nothing your Moloch own
snake guy what about a snake going
through a skull will depends you've been
to prison no these guys were fast
learners still we were looking for final
proof they were thinking acting and
feeling like rock stars oh hey guys
what's up hey where you going oh we just
booked a new worldwide tour so we're
gonna need your bus
rock on that's when we knew
the students had become the masters
you